Would
you guys move this back a little bit so
we can so I can see?
Could you help him
just a little? That's good.
[Silence]
I thought you were staying in Phoenix.
Look at you. I was going to say, why is
the masjid so bright?
Turns out Abdi was here. brought all his
light with him.
[Silence]
Continuing
in
in the book of fasting,
the chapter regarding the
pillars of fasting.
We were discussing the second pillar of
fasting which is refraining from
anything that would break a person's
fast.
And then the author lists those things
that will break a person's fast.
The author cites six things as
being the six things that will
compromise a person's fast.
Meaning that these six things will make
it so that if a person does them
purposely, they must make that day up
again.
And so the first and second was eating
and drinking purposely. Eating and
drinking purposely.
And the scholars
have explained what is meant by eating
or drinking. And that is that anything
foreign goes down the throat. Anything
foreign that goes down the throat,
whether it be by way of mouth or by way
of the nose. not the eyes and not the
ears. These are not considered
direct paths to the throat. The
direct paths to the throat are the mouth
and the nose.
And
we mentioned that this has to be
something that is done purposely
meaning a person knows that they're
fasting.
and remember at the moment and they
proceed to then
knowingly
eat or drink anything that will
compromise their fast. This will break a
person's fast.
Now,
it also warrants mentioning that
anything that would take the place of
food and drink, even if it is not by way
of the throat, even if it is not by way
of the mouth and nose. What do we mean
by that? Well, let's say a person were
to use an IV drip, right?
This is something that is used to
nourish the body
in place of food and drink or let's say
a bag that were to go or a tube that
were to go directly into the stomach,
right? And a person were to take
nourishment through that,
this will count as eating and drinking,
right? If a person's in such a state
that they need to have IV or they need
to have
you know
what do they call this the
feeding tube right or going in through
the throat or anything into the stomach
then this person is beyond ill. This
person doesn't need to be fasting in the
first place. However, if a person were
to use this, this would break a person's
fast. Why? Because the spirit of the
commandment is eating and drinking.
And the spirit of the prohibition is
that a person refrain from that which
nourishes the body
by way of eating and drinking or
anything that takes food or drinks place
in that sense. This will break a
person's fast. However,
if it is not designed to take the place
of food and drink,
for instance, a vitamin shot,
right? or insulin
or
you know any of these kinds of things
that are not designed to take the place
of food and drink but they are a kind of
vitamin or a kind of nourishment but not
a nourishment that takes the place of
food and drink. This will not break a
person's fast. Is that a clear
distinction in your mind? So there are
things that nourish the body a a
B12 shot, vitamins, right? Or things
that are used as a partial nourishment.
or for instance for diabetes,
insulin, right, which is produced in the
body, but it is a reaction to eating and
drinking or for instance something
that is partially designed to nourish
the body. This will not break a person's
fast. What will break a person's fast is
taking something that is designed to
substitute food and drink. This will
break a person's fast. Why? Well, it may
not go down the throat, but it is in
direct conflict with the spirit of the
prohibition.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasallam said
that Allah himself said regarding the
person who fasts. He said
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
speaks of the person fasting and says
that the person fasting leaves off his
food and drink and sexual gratification
for my sake. So the spirit of fasting is
exactly that narration. The narration is
in Bkari is exactly captured in that
narration which is leaving off food and
drink and sexual gratification. This is
the spirit of fasting. And so taking
something, introducing something into
the body that will take the place of
food and drink is in direct conflict
with the spirit of fasting and the
purpose of fasting. Therefore, it will
break a person's fast.
The author then cites the evidence. We
mentioned that evidence is the
difference between knowledge and
right
which is to just follow right to when
we say follow we could actually call
imitate to imitate right the scholars
agree that imitation
is not considered knowledge this is an
issue of consensus Abd
in his book on knowledge
mentions that
the scholars all agree and have reached
consensus
that an imitator is not a scholar is not
a person of knowledge. Let's say we had
a person that memorized
an entire
memorized volumes of books with
respect to the opinions of the scholars
of Islam, right? And any subject that
you mention, they will cite to you all
four m this med this is the opinion.
This m this is the opinion. This MB,
this is the opinion. But if they are
asked what the evidence is, evidence is
Quran, Sunnah,
the and that which is associated with
Quran and Sunnah. So Quran, Sunnah,
the words of the companions, the fatawa
of the companions, right? So if if this
person were to be asked about the
evidences for this, they don't know the
evidences. They only know what the final
opinions of the scholars are. This is
not a person of knowledge. This may be a
person of knowledge with respect to the
opinions of the scholars. He knows what
the scholars said, but he doesn't know
why they said it. And that is what
knowledge is. Knowledge is
knowing that which is correct with its
evidence
with its evidence from the Quran and
Sunnah. So this is why we mention the
evidence and you know it's really sad
sometimes when you see the general
attitude of a lot of people with respect
to the evidence right when you go to I
mean even myself people will ask me a
question a lot of times they'll ask a
question and I'll begin with mentioning
the answer and then citing the evidence
they tune in for the answer and then
their eyes glaze is over when I mention
the evidence I say the answer to this
question is
you know the following because Allah
said in this verse and their eyes just
glaze over and they zone out they check
out as if to say well that doesn't
really concern me what concerns me is
just the ev the the final conclusion and
you know anything beyond that is the
dominion of you know the domain of
scholars. That's not correct at all.
Have we been commanded? Who have we been
commanded to follow
the Quran and Sunnah?
Oh, you who have believed, obey Allah
and obey his messenger. That's the
nature of what we were commanded.
Obedience to the scholars or or
following the scholars or imitating the
scholars. This is in the instance in
which we are unable to arrive at the
evidence. Right?
That's the idea. Ask the people of
knowledge if you do not know. If you
don't have knowledge, you don't know the
verse, you don't know the narration.
And so most of the Quran and Sunnah is
understandable.
Most of the Quran and Sunnah is clear.
Most of the Quran and Sunnah and all of
it is clear to the people of knowledge.
Right?
So we want to change this culture. We
want to change the culture of just take
the opinion and don't worry about the
evidence. We want to change that.
Why? Because we want to learn and we do
not want to have a culture of knowledge
is only for scholars.
No, we have to learn the knowledge.
and doesn't mean every single one of us
is going to be a scholar, but it does
mean that we will at least learn how to
identify a scholar. And at least we are
worshiping Allah based on what Allah has
said because that's your responsibility.
Your responsibility is to prepare your
argument in front of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala for the day of judgment to get
to get prepared.
So the evidence
that eating and drinking on the day
during the day of Ramadan is one of the
things that will break a person's fast
purposely. He says
And then he
he says that if a person were to eat or
drink something having forgotten that he
is fasting then this person does not
have to make that day up and this person
does not have to pay an expeation and
this person's fast is correct. they are
to continue their fasting.
The evidence, the general evidence that
eating and drinking breaks a person's
fast, we all know that, right? We
all know that eating and drinking breaks
a person's fast. But what's the
evidence? We we've gone down this
before, right? We've done this before.
The evidence, one of the evidences is
the statement of Allah
verse number 187 of
Allah says and eat and drink
and before that he says
he speaks about the sexual
gratification
meaning and Sleep with your wives and
eat and drink until the thread of dawn
becomes distinguished to you from the
thread of night, meaning the break of
dawn on the horizon.
Then
continue to fast until nightfall.
Nightfall in the Arabic language begins
linguistically speaking at the time the
sun sets.
Meaning the dis of the sun
sets under the horizon. Even if there's
a lot of light, night begins once the
disc of the sun is no longer visible.
Once it is no longer visible, that is
nightfall. That is considered night in
the Arabic language. And Allah sent the
Quran in which language? Quran and
Arabian
that it is an Arabic recitation. And so
the essence of all of the Quran and
Sunnah is that it is in Arabic and
whatever the Arabs understand it to mean
is what it means unless otherwise
stipulated. So night is when the
sun the dis of the sun is no longer
visible. Right.
He says
one of the most heartfelt
most touching statements of our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. Abu narrates that
our prophet said sai wasallam. The
narration is in Bkari Muslim. He says
the narration many of us are familiar
with or at least its meaning.
Abu narrates that our prophet
sallall.aii Wasam said, "Whoever forgets
while he is fasting and eats or drinks,
then he is to continue his fast for
indeed it is Allah who has fed him and
you know given him to drink.
So we understand from the narration
that if a person eats or drinks
something forgetting you forget you're
fasting your your body's on autopilot
you eat something you drink something
right
will this break a person's fast no as
long as they don't do it having
remembered and on purpose
so as long as the person stops stops as
soon as they remember
then their fast is still valid. They are
still fasting.
And notice the words that the prophet
use. He says
then he is to continue his fast. Meaning
he's still fasting, right? He considers
this legislatively a fast
because eating and drinking only breaks
a person's fast when they know they have
knowledge of this. And this falls into
the general rule
that Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala said
in
our Lord do not hold us to account if we
forget. Closing verses of Bakar and Sah
Muslim the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said that Allah responded.
I have done so. I have answered this
dua. And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
does not hold us to account if we
forget.
A person may say, well, you know what's
what's so special about that? How could
you hold someone to account if they
forget?
When a person forgets,
they forget something this.
What is the root cause of that
forgetfulness?
Ignorance.
More negligence.
Wouldn't you agree? Negligence.
Yeah, there is an air of negligence
there. When a person forgets, that's why
Allah forgave us for it. Otherwise, what
is he forgiving us for? When a person
forgets
something this,
it has an air of negligence with it. You
forgot because you were neglectful.
Otherwise, why did you forget?
If I say to you for instance,
it's the human nature to forget but
not forget the most major important
things. If you had a million dollars
sitting in a bag, would you forget about
them?
Let's say you gave me a million dollars
to watch over and then I say, "Man, I
forgot it on a park bench. I'm sorry,
man. I forgot it.
, would you accept that? Why not? I
forgot. It's human nature. What's What's
your problem? Huh? I forgot.
You would be very upset and you would
hold me to account, wouldn't you? Even
though you believe that I forgot.
Why would you hold me to account?
Not because I did it on purpose, but
because there is an heir of what?
Negligence.
That's why Allah has forgiven us for it.
That's specific to this the previous
would be held to account if they
forgot. If they forgot a salah, if they
forgot their fasting, if they forgot
the prophet, listen to this narration.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam said,
he said,
He said, "Allah has pardoned my nation
for me. He has pardoned for me my
nation." Meaning previous nations. No,
he has pardoned for me my nation.
that which is done in error,
that which they forget, and that which
they are forced to do, compelled against
their will. That wasn't the case in the
previous nations. In the previous
nations, if you are held over a boiling
a boiling pot of grease and said,
"We'll drop you in if you don't say if
you don't denounce your faith." They had
to go into Greece
and it did happen. That was their rules.
They could not do something out of
compulsion.
This
Allah forgave. We don't have the baggage
that Ben is.
We're not suffering from that baggage.
Allah made it specific to this ummah. He
has pardoned us for mistake,
errors, forgetfulness
and what we are compelled
to do.
Why is he pardoning something that no
don't take that for granted.
He's pardoning us for
an air of negligence.
There is negligence involved when a
person forgets his salah, forgets his
fasting, forgets he is fasting, forgets
he forgets a verse from the Quran after
he's memorized it. Forget there's an air
of negligence
even though it's forgetting. Yes, it was
only forgotten because it was on the
back burner. If it was in the front and
forefront of your mind, you would not
have forgotten about it, right?
So we will continue this tomorrow
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
No, that doesn't break your back, but it
might break your body.